we're gonna girl talk now if that's okay
yes please let's do that all right
we're gonna girl talk with andra day
here we go
okay typical girl question slash
everybody wants to know have you figured
out what you're wearing
do you like it do you feel good about it
yes i have actually i know exactly what
i'm wearing
i'm so excited about it i feel great
about i mean can i say am i supposed to
say did we say that
well is it prada i can't i don't know if
i could say but i'm saving prada for
another event that we're hoping for but
um the golden globes on sunday i'm
wearing um actually a chanel
dress oh
i didn't know that
how are you feeling like do you want to
prepare a speech do you want to like
wing it are you a jinxer are you
how are you approaching it i'm
definitely more of a winging it kind of
person i like to just speak
whatever the kind of spirit speaks in
the moment you know
but then i'm the other part of it is i
want to make sure i don't miss anybody
so i'm probably going to like write
every name out because that's really all
i want to do is just get up there and
just say thank you to
everybody who poured into me so heavily
for this role
i am i was lucky enough uh to
uh get a golden globe for grey gardens
and um
i forgot to thank jessica lange
because i basically blacked out uh yeah
cause like so you recommend me writing
the names down definitely
it's like there was only one person one
i freaked out i freaked out
i i i think i was just trying not to
vomit
yeah i think that's the main thing i
um i are you going uh do you have a date
oh i mean my date to the golden globes
will be
my mama so
she's the best date you know what i mean
she's just like where we have fun we
know each other really well
she keeps me nice and grounded my dad as
well too so
my family will be with me for that so
that's the it's
the one like although i'm sad we can't
be in person
you know for for the globes the one
thing about you know kind of virtually
doing it is i can have everybody with me
so that's
the lesson you know i can't think of
anyone
who deserves every good thing that
is coming your way because you built it
you earned it
and i love the song rise up
and in it is such a perfect song in
itself for
all of the recognition um it garnered
and warranted because
of what it represents but in it
is such a beautiful thing to listen to
compared to when you sing billy and
i'm so glad it's out there as a a
comparison
because you channel her in
ways i i i'm sure people did not think
possible but it is possible
thank you thank you so much and i mean
and thank you to her right because it
was
her singing such a horrible song and
that that's
one thing that i i always tell people
when i was on set the thing that changed
the most for me listening to strange
fruit was it
you know before i was trying to honor
billy singing strange fruit right you
know and and honor her legacy and honor
but on set being her it was like
every time people would clap for the
song i'd be like it's such a beautiful
song it would like make me angry because
i'm like how can you say a song about
the burning flesh of my ancestors and
the twisted mouth and the blood on the
leaves and blood at the root it's a
horrible song
and it's the lynching is a horrific
sight but it was her singing that
terrible song that really opened it up
for me to be able to sing
a song like rise up i just as a
someone who grew up in storytelling and
filmmaking
what you and lee daniels and all of your
fellow
crew and cast members crafted to support
the strange fruit moment was the perfect
build-up
and honoring and understanding and
earning that moment
and the trajectory of the film is sheer
structural perfection it's unbelievable
that means the world i wish we could
hear this i'm literally probably going
to call him as soon as i get off
here because i that's i think what he
wants people to understand and
with what we were doing he didn't want
to do a straight ahead biopic you know
what i mean he wanted
to tell the truth of her story in in art
you know as a beautiful
time capsule where you could still
experience black excellence and black
opulence and
what he was so inspired by in ladies
things of blues and then to also get the
truth of how the government went
after her for for being a change maker
you know and
and being this civil rights leader so
it's you just like
understood it and articulated it so
perfectly
in a way that just makes me love you
even more love you so much
i am just rooting for you for every
reason
in the world thank you andrea day the
united states
versus billy holliday is available on
hulu
tomorrow this is the premiere
[Music]